what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so I was going through injustice
year five and one of the things that I
realize is that we really need to do the
annual for injustice year for now as a
rule I've kind of avoided the annuals
and the reason why is because for the
most part they're more entertaining than
actually necessary to the story but your
four is pretty necessary it's you know
the year for annual is actually kind of
required and the reason why is because
with the injustice line of stories
here's one two and three were really
really fun but the question anybody had
is how did those segue into the game
gear for began the process of that
transition and then year five really
kind of finishes it out and basically
end going into the game with regards to
to getting from year forty year five the
annual takes care of that for us and so
it's really kind of a necessary piece of
reading year but what I wanted to do is
really kind of go through this because
this focuses on the concept of the
character of Plastic Man and it's
actually raising some really really cool
moral arguments to because what's
basically happened at the beginning of
this year for annual is it a handful of
terrorists have basically taken down a
Superman statue now these are not these
Beach geyser news I mean that's
basically what they are you know these
guys have no idea what they're doing
they take down a statue and they don't
really they don't understand the impact
of what it is they're doing to them
we're just committing an act of
revolution against the you know the
regime of Superman in reality they're
sending a huge moral message and that's
really the issue here the reason why is
because in the realm of injustice we get
some really interesting philosophical
arguments on freedom and security
a really cool idea here is that with
Batman in a scheme they fight on the
part of freedom they fight on the idea
of a free society but Superman's
argument could be well if you have
freedom then show me your freedom put
your freedom in the palm of my hand if
you believe in freedom so strongly and
surely if something is tangible
surely it's something that that exists
if you believe it's something that is
inherently entitled to you then show me
where your freedom is and if they can't
do that well then the response to
Superman is well freedom is simply a
privilege but no one's bothered to take
away yet but I'm taking that privilege
away I'm taking away your right to be
free there's nothing you can do to stop
me which is true but on the other side
of the coin
Batman makes the convincing case because
if freedom was a tangible object Howie
see what it'd be to keep her protected
you just throw it to safe nobody can
access it you put it in the center of
town surrounded by armed guards so
everybody can see how valuable it is but
you also make sure there's a measure of
protection if freedom was a tangible
thing it would be so easy to protect but
freedom exists only so long as there are
people who are willing to fight for it
and that's why this idea of injustice is
so cool in terms we 5 people that have
no real idea what it is they're doing
because what it tells us is that so long
as there are people who are willing to
stand up to Superman's regime then
freedom will always exist they'll always
inspire people to continue fighting
because what they're doing is promoting
an idea an idea is something that cannot
be physically destroyed so long as
somebody believes in it it will live on
forever and so the cool thing about this
is that what we also learn from Barry
Allen is that there are there basically
six people who are involved in this but
we only see pods and the question is why
do we only see five well then from here
we pick up with a guy who basically has
the ability to shape-shift and make
himself into different objects physical
and so on and so forth and the initial
indication seems to be the dysplastic
Man what in reality is actually Plastic
Man son and that's kind of cool but
almost immediately after he makes his
presence known he's taken out by
Superman time is really grabbed by
Superman and just kind of moved away now
I guess you know taken to their local
prison now from here we actually come
into the character of O'Brien with
plastic man himself
and this is awesome because what
happened is rivaled a little basically
sits down and says Plastic Man is no
laughing matter this guy's not a goof of
course Plastic Man is the predecessor to
Reed Richards right you know Plastic Man
appeared in 1941 Reed Richards appeared
some twenty years later and it's just
one of those instances where Marvel and
DC borrow they give and take from one
another and use that to kind of bolster
their own landscape and so it creates an
interesting situation because what is up
happening here is by virtue of Superman
Wonder Woman different people they're
basically making the case that Plastic
Man is going to come for his son and
when he does they have to be on alert
now of course with Sinestro but he
doesn't really consider Plastic Man to
be any measure of a threat he's like
this is ridiculous why are we worried
about him it's really because Wonder
Woman Superman
cyborg those guys chime in and say
because Plastic Man is probably the most
dangerous out of all of us you have no
idea how dangerous this guy is and it's
true and that's why Plastic Man fans
love him that's why they they absolutely
adore this guy so he never gets any
respect one of our
never going to release a Justice League
movie and have plastic man in there
because people would be like well that's
stupid but Plastic Man is a super
capable guy and the reason why is
because he can basically do whatever he
wants with his body he's literally a man
made of plastic he could make himself
invertible to physical harm he's a
mortal he can shape-shift into virtually
anything he can take on massive amounts
of sizing and stretch his body out he
could do all kinds of crazy stuff he's
extremely intelligent if we were to say
you know for example plastic man vs.
Superman I would say Plastic Man under
normal circumstances would win the issue
is that Superman has frost breath and
plastic man's biggest weakness is
extreme cold if Superman didn't have
frost breath Plastic Man would win and
so it creates a really cool situation
because it's only by one little thing
let's Superman comes out on top and that
shows you how close the two of them are
to one another the evil of Plastic Man
coming in here he's always been some
measure with Joker right like Plastic
Man in the in you know the mainline DC
comics are really before the new 52
he was always be Joker of the group he
was always a light-hearted guy he was
always the one that injected humor into
stories that would have otherwise been
extremely serious tower Babel is a
really good example throughout all the
events that were going on the fact that
Plastic Man was almost destroyed when he
was frozen and then shattered he always
kept it cool he always kept a little bit
of humor in there he was always kind of
a funny guy and so because of that it's
really this situation where he walks in
you know and it's a little bit of humor
which turns into anger and the reason
why it turns into anger is because of
the fact that Superman and his team will
not listen the reason they're so far
gone and that's the crazy thing is
because project man's will the outside
looking in we have not seen his I've
seen him yet we've not seen him in the
story and so it's basically a guy who's
kind of been on the outside looking in
he hasn't been part of Batman he hasn't
been part of Superman walking in and
basically saying you guys have no idea
how far you've fallen and that's the
case that's being made here it's Brian
Brooke a little saying that's sitting
down and saying this is the frog in
boiling water versus water this being
turned up you take take a frog you throw
into a pot of boiling water it'll try
its best to get out of there but if you
take a frog and you put it in a pot of
water and gradually turn up the heat
it'll just boil to death and that's
exactly what's happening here like
Superman was the guy who started out
with the best of intentions only to find
himself making you know concession every
step of the way he just he drew a line
in the sand you know and he said this is
a line that we don't cross and then they
cross the line so we drew another line
it said this is the line that we don't
cross and then they drop they cross that
line and so we drew another line it's a
this is the line that we don't cross he
kept making concessions every single
step of the way it's like I to the point
that he just fell just found himself
tumbling down this rabbit hole of being
a bad guy and became the villain became
B villain and that's what's so ironic
about this for decades and decades and
decades in DC Comics Superman was a
protector of the world always a
protector of humanity always this right
beacon in the sky that humanity would
aspire to become and this story keeps
the bad guy he's the threat to humanity
and so a creature is really really cool
visually cool concepts and so what is
happening here is Barry Allen and
Plastic Man actually go for some
measurable walkers because of the fact
that Superman says you're not getting
your son back and what's cool about this
is it's kind of you know boo Collett oh
you know harkening back to the whole
aspect of Plastic Man having been part
of the Justice League having served a
long part of the Justice League being
friends with various members and then he
basically lures Barry Allen down an
alleyway and then subdues and that
really shows you what's so cool about
this now in terms of the core reason for
why he's doing this the motivation is
simply to be a major part of his son
that's really what he says I mean where
cyborg shows up and basically wakes
flash up says hey man is everything okay
we basically end up finding out that
Plastic Man more or less moves flash out
of the way or you know kind of has a
hidden really for the most part and that
what's going on is that this version of
flash is basically Plastic Man that's
really what's going on here and so the
idea is that with Plastic Man
orchestrating his sons escape from the
trench which is where this prison for
super those is being helped he says that
in his mind he always left his son
hanging that he never he was never
really there for a son when his son
needed him better that as being a member
of the Justice League it always took up
so much of his time he never went to his
son's you know major events he never
went to his son's baseball games you
know he was never a major part of his
son's life and it's him sitting down and
saying this is my chance to be a part of
my son's life
and that's why this works so well
because whether is because of the jobs
that we work whether it's because maybe
we have kids and we're going back to
school you know whatever the case may be
even military life there are a lot of
parents out there mothers and fathers
alike who sit down and say I wish I
could spend more time with my kids but I
can't because of X Y & Z and X Y & Z
allows me to put a roof over their head
it allows me to put food on the table it
allows you to put clothes on their back
I have to make the sacrifice of spending
time with my child nor dur to make sure
that my child can have the things that
my child needs in order to be healthy in
order to grow up in order
enjoyed their life even though they
don't have me in it as much as they
would like and that's the cool thing
about this but of course we don't having
plastic man basically just kind of
breaking into this prison that's what's
so ironic about it is because he can
infiltrate virtually anything if there
is a room and that room has some way to
access he can get in the other half of
this is that we also find out what ended
up happening to a bunch of the members
of the Green Lantern Corps
the biggest issue was that a lot of the
concepts with the Green Lantern Corps
were that allows them were killed but
then a lot of them were also to sort of
taken prisoner it wouldn't really know
that at the time we just knew they were
stripped of their reigns but we didn't
really know what it was a Sinestro had
done with them and so we basically find
a whole lot of them just being held down
in this trench prison I'll keep in mind
because of the fact that members of the
Green Lantern Corps are nothing without
their rings all they had to do is take
their wings away and they're just normal
people so there's kind of kept in
general population but what is up
happening is Plastic Man goes - Kilowog
and says I need to know where my son is
look McDonough do you have any idea
where he's located at now of course
Kilowog responses people with
superpowers are kept in isolation so
they can't orchestrate a prison break
which makes sense trans man also says
look I need you guys to create a
distraction now I love the way this
distraction goes down I love the way
this distraction happen Kilowog is a
badass right like like he's a dude that
will ring or no ring he'll fight to the
death he runs up on Bank right and he's
just like I have no idea how to insult
your mother in your language so I'm just
going to headbutt the hell out of you
and it just orchestrates this huge
prison fight that's really all it is
it's just it's just some bar fight in a
prison and it's amazing to see because
it's just everybody finding everybody
else and that's one of the reasons why
Plastic Man is so intelligent because
you got to keep in mind these guys all
these different villains they're one
trying to avoid their own nature which
is to create conflict and two they're
just filled with anger and rage because
in their minds they're being you know
incarcerated unjustly and that's true
for a lot of these guys a lot of these
guys were already in prison at the time
but they were serving out their prison
sentence but the idea is that there was
certainly a prison sentence they would
pay their debt to society and then they
would be allowed to go free in this
Superman regime there is no freedom they
were criminals at one point they
committed a crime at one point in their
life and so now they're going to be in
jail forever
but in the end he's able of course it
break into the cell where his son's
located at and free his son the problem
is that in the process the warden
realizes what it is the Plastic Man is
doing he triggers the alarm and he frees
some of the more super-powered villains
now what happens with this is it's
basically this idea that a lot of these
people
villains are being brainwashed or
they're being used by Superman for the
purpose of serving as an army that will
be a huge part of your thoughts but
that's the process it's basically being
undergone at this particular point in
time but of course then we end up seeing
the the appearance of Metamorpho now of
course Metamorpho is a character that
can turn himself into a lot of different
materials you can literally metamorph
into a multitude different things that
gaseous form liquid forms so on and so
forth but he's basically the warden here
the reason being because of the fact
that if there were a riot that were to
break out he could basically turn into
whatever it is that he needs to turn
into in order to quell the riot and so
of course with Superman's arrival on the
scene the biggest issue they have is for
plastic bands in here they're literally
in the trench which is a prison in the
extreme depth and pressures of the ocean
what are they going to do to get out
well the responsive Plastic Man is give
the Green Lantern's their green back and
that's exactly what happens the Green
Lantern's get all their rings and they
basically have a chance to stand up
against the next row now well that's
what's cool about this is because now
which the return of the Green Lantern
Corps the issue is on as far as I know
they're probably they probably want up
here again I haven't read the entirety
of your five so please don't spoil it
for me but of course Sinestro and the
process kills Kilowog now the death of
Kilowog was not an action it wasn't like
Sinestro just kind of blind fired into
the building and then shot whoever it is
that he happened to shoot and it just
turned out to be Kilowog Kilowog is a
rallying force for the Green Lantern a
lot of them were trained by Kilowog and
so there's a lot of respect for him and
so if anybody was going to rally all the
Green Lantern's to a single cause it
would be Kilowog not to mention Kilowog
with the exception of Hal Jordan is the
most capable of all the existing Green
Lantern's and so if there were anybody
that could lead a force that included
Batman and what's left of the earth
superheroes and villains against the
regime of Superman and proved to be
successful it would have been Kilowog
the issue here is that with him
presumably dead and of course a hole in
this dump it leads to a massive calamity
I mean it's really just water pouring in
the pressures pouring in and what is it
happening here this plastic man of
course holds the waters a day now the
idea here seems to be the book a lot of
setting up in the direction of a plastic
man's going to sacrifice his life but
this also shows us the ingenuity that he
has how intelligent he is and how far
ahead he plans
what are you done if he had basically
taken the belt of mirror master I
remember the very oh the belt of mere
matter basically creates portals it
creates mirrors to a degree any object
that can reflect an image
be used as a mirror and so the idea is
create a portal and send them somewhere
else
and that have the engineer their escape
mirror masters belt leads through the
mass escape of all these prisoners that
are being held in place and it's so cool
because the other half here seems to be
the plastic man's going to die I mean
he's his body stretching it's not really
able to hold out against these forces
but his Sun comes up and it son says
look I recognize that you you feel like
you haven't been the best father ever
but don't be stupid don't sacrifice your
life for something stupid come on with
me and we'll get out of here and that's
exactly what happens Plastic Man in a
son basically just bail out but the
other cool thing about this this was
something that had never really really
been thought about before is Plastic Man
and his son
address all the different villains that
are there and of course in a plastic
man's son you know and son Luke is just
kind of like look I mean we freed all
these villains that's cool we're in the
you know the mirror masters realm are we
really just gonna let them go for free
like go back out in the world and do bad
things because all we've done is just
enabled a whole bunch of super villains
you know I mean as cool it you rescued
me but who knows what kind of danger
they would pose to society as a whole
and so this is really cool because
Plastic Man sits down with all the
villains and says hey look guys I know
you I know you're bad guys like I know
some of the guys some of you guys are
just like pigs like some of you guys are
just really bad people but if you're
gonna do bad stuff do it in a way that
makes you the men's like how it'd be bad
guys and make Superman's life rough
don't hurt innocent people just makes
you a man's life really rough and killer
killer Crocs like yeah I mean I guess I
mean sure I don't see why not and it's
just a really funny situation here but
what this does is again the annuals are
really kind of self-contained in a lot
of ways the adventure the story are
largely self-contained to a degree in
the sense that it's really Plastic Man
and a son just kind of leaving you know
and they're like well we just kind of
hide we could just go underground and to
a more qualified people take them down
and that's really it but again this is a
pretty fun little story it's an
interesting little story I enjoyed it I
mean it was it was pretty cool to go
through it but if you guys are new here
the comments explained make sure you
guys are the sub button to become part
of the rod force you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you on it
please
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]